And here we go. Hello Sean. Hey Joe. How's it going?
Thanks for being here again man. I really appreciate it. So, uh,
over the weekend I got into your book. Woo. Yes, yes,
it's great. Thank you. I mean,
I really appreciate someone like you who's trying to break down quantum
mechanics and quantum physics. For someone like me,
it's very hard to follow and there was a lot of backing up and trying it again
and backing up and trying it again and like going over paragraphs and trying to
figure out exactly what it means. But, uh, it's,
it's really excellent and really perplexing at the same time. Well, thank you.
And you know,
there are different styles when it comes to writing poppy of the books.
I think there should be different styles. And my particular style is, look,
it's not going to be a breezy page Turner. Uh,
but if you read it carefully, like there's not prerequisites,
you don't have to come into it as an expert would you have to come into it is
someone who's willing to sit and think about every paragraph and then hopefully
it will be rewarding.
And you'll truly understand what's going on after doing that.
While it is rewarding because it is fascinating and the history of quantum
physics is also pretty fascinating cause I've always wondered like,
how did anybody even want to come up with this stuff like this?
And the fact that it was so long ago,
it was what the beginnings of it were in the 19th century. Well,
1900 is the typical, literally that year,
the turn of the century when Lux plonk first, uh, got the first 10th of it,
and then yeah, it took another 27 years to put into final shape.
Now for regular people that don't have a background of physics or that don't,
this is like the whole idea behind it is so bizarre.
It's like why would anybody try to figure out something that,
one of the things that you said that's really interesting is that you,
quantum physics is used all the time.
It's used with exact calculations,
but yet we don't really understand it. Yeah, yeah. No,
that's the main message of the book really.
Because physicists of course do quantum mechanics every day, whether it's,
you know, straightforward quantum mechanics, quantum field theory,
quantum information, quantum computing, clearly we're pretty good at it.
You know, like transistors and lasers depend on quantum mechanics.
The sun shining, figuring that out depends on quantum mechanics,
the Higgs bows on, et cetera.
So to claim that we don't understand quantum mechanics is a little bit weird,
but then we have quotes from people like Richard FIMAN saying,
nobody understands quantum mechanics, right? And so if he says that,
then there's some authority behind it.
And the reason is what we have is sort of a black box, right?
We say, you know what?
I think what I said in a New York times article I wrote recently is physicists
understand quantum mechanics.
In the same way that someone who owns a smartphone understands the smartphone,
like they know how to use the apps. They can call people, they can make phone,
they can take pictures, they don't know what's going on inside.
And that's physicists with quantum mechanics. They, they use it.
They can make very, very precise predictions.
But if you ask them what is really going on, like what is actually happening,
what are all the details? They're like, yeah, no, that's not our job.
Let's just stick to prediction.
But to someone like me, that's so terrifying because like the,
the very nature of reality is being examined by people.
Like if, if it is us of smartphone,
it's being examined by people like me who don't really understand the
smartphone. I have no idea what, what's going on inside a smart phone.
I have no,
I know some words that have you used to describe Ram and process,
sorry. Electrons moving around in there, right?
Yeah. And I think, and in some sense that's fine.
Like most of us don't need to know what's going on inside the smart phone to use
it, but somebody should know. Right.
And my argument in the book is look, the,
if 500 years from now when historians write the history of 20th century physics,
they will say two things. Uh, one is my God,
these people were so brilliant and creative to invent quantum mechanics and then
they were so afraid to really take it seriously.
And try to understand it. Like they said,
like stop asking questions about the meaning of reality and what the world is
doing. In my mind,
what physics is all about is understanding reality and what the world is doing.
It's not just about making predictions, making predictions is good.
But we do that, you know,
mostly because we're curious about what the world is doing
well for people outside the world of academia.
When I read someone like you saying that you were discouraged from pursuing this
and you literally told that you should be pursuing your work and cosmology and
gravitation is that's where it's at. That's serious work. Yeah. That,
that seems to me's be so crazy. It's like if anybody should be pursuing it,
it should be people like you.
Yeah. I mean I want to be fair. So, of course,
20th century physics was incredibly successful and, and there was,
part of the attitude was, look,
we have to understand nuclear physics and particle physics. And you know,
a lot of it was the center of physics shifted from Europe to the U S and Europe
is much more philosophical and you're willing to think about the deep ideas.
And Americans are pretty pragmatic and want to build things right.
In particular at the time they wanted to build nuclear weapons.
And so the idea of just really putting aside deep philosophical issues and
putting stuff to work was attractive. And the other issue is, you know, okay,
let's say we do demand that we understand quantum mechanics better.
How do you do it? Like what experiment is it there that you can do as,
as far as we know, the cookbook that we have,
even though we don't understand it works pretty well. Like what,
what could you type into your smartphone that would help you understand what's
going on inside? It's kind of hard to figure out.
So I think that those attitudes were wrong, but at least you know,
they're not completely crazy. It's not just that they, uh,
were afraid of the truth or anything like that.
And I also think that it is finally changing now. I think that there's slowly,
slowly,
slowly more people are appreciating the understanding quantum mechanics is
important. What do you attribute that to? Um, a couple of things. One is,
I mean there's good news and bad news that part of the good news is technology
has gotten better. So we're trying to build quantum computers for example.
And guess what, you know,
some of the ad hoc rules that we had for doing quantum mechanics might not be up
to the task. We need to understand the details a little bit better. Um,
the other Saturday thing is that so much a fundamental physics is kind of stuck
right now. Right?
We haven't [inaudible] we literally have not been surprised by a new
experimental result in fundamental physics since the 1970s.
Uh, the one, there's one exception to that,
which is the universe accelerating in 1998, which was the dark energy. Um,
we've had amazing accomplishments in experimental and observational physics.
We found the Higgs bows on. We found the top quark,
we found gravitational waves, the microwave background, many, many things,
but they were all predicted decades ago. Right.
So progress is driven by being surprised and it's been a long time since we've
been surprised. So some people, including myself say,
well one of the things to do in that situation is to take a step back and
reexamined the foundations.
Maybe maybe we can take a broader look and think that we were walking down the
wrong path.
Now for people who don't have any background in physics there there's a a bit of
an issue with the public perception.
And one of the things about public perception,
it's films like what the bleep yeah.
That sort of throw this sort of cultish monkey wrench into the,
you know,
w w quantum physics is weird enough as it is without adding let,
that movie was literally created by a channeler, right?
A friend of mine, David Albert,
who was one of the leading philosophers of physics,
and I should also give credit to philosophers here because they haven't taken
quantum mechanics seriously longer than the physicist have to be honest. Um,
so David is one of the many people who got a PhD in physics and then switched to
philosophy because he cared about the foundations of quantum mechanics and no
physics department would ever hire him. Right. And uh, yeah,
I tell the story through the back door. Yeah. I tell the story in the book,
like he wrote a bunch of influential papers as a graduate student and then he
went and said, uh, I would like to, you know, make these papers my PhD thesis.
And they said, no, that's not really serious physics.
And they punished him by making him write this incredibly technical mathematical
paper on quantum field theory just to prove he could do it. And then he's like,
this, I don't want to take this anymore. I'm switching fields. But anyway,
he was in that film.
He was in what the bleep and they lied to him.
They misrepresented themselves. They said,
we're doing a documentary about quantum mechanics.
And they sat him down for three hours and asked him all these,
you're leading questions like,
doesn't this mean that we're bringing reality into existence by looking at it?
And, and he's like, no, that's not what it means. Let me explain to you.
But then in the final film, there's like 32nd clips of him going, yes,
that is a really important question, right?
Like completely misrepresenting what he said.
And so he went public after that and uh, and complained about and,
uh, about the film. And he did in a hilarious story, there was a,
uh, event,
some sort of convention put on in Santa Monica by supporters of the film that
they thought it'd be fun to get all of the people who were in the movie,
what the bleep do we know and get them at, you know,
and talk to them and then charge people money to listen to them.
But these people were not affiliated with the filmmakers,
so they didn't know that David Albert had been completely misrepresented in the
film.
So they invited him and he goes to this event in Santa Monica and he gave a
talk, you know, he, he decided, you know, he wondered like,
should I just go at all? But okay, why not? Let's reach a different audience.
And he, he gave a talk and he said, look,
there's two things you can do when you are faced with fundamental puzzles of
reality.
One is you can face up to what the world is trying to tell you and you can
accept it and take it as what it is, no matter what you like.
The other is you can choose to tell a flattering story about yourself.
And the people who made this movie have decided that the mysteries of quantum
mechanics are really stories about how they are powerful and have influence over
reality and so forth. But it's all nonsense.
And the punchline is the audience loved it.
They went nuts because what they wanted was a guru of some sort.
And like he was just as good as anybody else. So you know,
he had a better story to do reality based Scality guru. Yeah. Yeah.
So I think you're right. I mean,
I think that quantum mechanics I've said before is a,
of all the theories in the history of science,
the most easily distorted and misrepresented in the popular mind.
Well,
you've done an amazing job in this book of trying to boil it down for dummies
like me. But it's hard. It is.
It is a complicated and insanely nuance subject. Yeah.
And it's one of those things where it's like this many worlds theory.
For one example, the, the, the,
just the possibility that there's like, explain that.
Explain for people that don't understand what quantum mechanics even means.
Give them just like a little bit of that and then explain many worlds theory.
Yeah, a good, this is what I'm here to do. So, you know,
an electron take an electron,
quantum mechanics should apply to the entire universe,
but it becomes unmistakable when you look at little tiny things, right?
So we always are talking about electrons or atoms and so forth.
And electron has a position and, well, sorry, let me not even say that,
that even that was wrong.
It's just so hard to correctly talk about quantum mechanics, right?
If you were Isaac Newton before there was quantum mechanics,
there was classical mechanics and basically quantum mechanics.
Classical mechanics are the only two big frameworks that have ever existed in
physics. You know,
classical mechanics was so good that everyone thought that was just right and
it's all a matter of filling the details.
Until quantum mechanics came along and changed things in classical mechanics and
electron is a point. It has a position, a location in space,
and it has a velocity.
It's moving somewhere and from that you can predict what's going to happen.
Okay? Quantum mechanics says, no, no, no.
The electron has a wave function, so there's a wave. You know,
sometimes you hear this debate about are are things like electrons and photons,
particles or waves. The answer is that they are waves
and the wave function has this weird property that when you're not looking at
it, it's a wave. It's all spread out or it's localized somewhere,
but it obeys an equation. The Schrodinger equation, so far so good.
Just like regular physics, there's a thing, the wave function,
it obeys an equation. The Schrodinger equation,
you can predict what's going to happen next,
but the weird thing about quantum mechanics is that there's a whole separate set
of rules for what happens when you look at the thing, when you observe it.
When you measure it,
that's where things get squirreled with people describing it, right? Yes.
And that's where they want to go. Woo. On you. It's an opening to be woo. Right?
When you say like,
what do you mean observe something like does it have to be a conscious being?
Can it be a video camera? You know, that's just fear, right?
Is it the act of measuring the changes things? Well,
this is the puzzle. Okay?
This is what is called the measurement problem of quantum mechanics.
That the rules we teach our students at Cal tech or anywhere else when we teach
them quantum mechanics in their sophomore year of college, uh,
the rules say when a system is observed,
when it is measured, it's state,
it's wave function changes dramatically suddenly and unpredictably. Now,
let me ask you this. How do we know this based on if,
if you're measuring it and it changes, how do we know?
Because we didn't measure it before.
Like what observations are we making that we understand the state of it before
it's measured without measuring it? Good. There's a couple of ways. So, um, let,
let, let me make things even simpler.
Forget about where the electron is located and think about the electron is
spinning, right? Electron is spinning. Just like the earth spins.
It's really exactly like that. It's like a little spinning top,
except when you measure the spin,
you can sort of send the electron through a magnetic field and it'll get deflect
either up or down, depending on whether it's spinning, spin up or spin down.
You only ever get one of two answers. It's either going up or going down.
It's nowhere in between. This is an empirical measured fact. Okay? Um,
so that's a part of quantum mechanics.
That's the quantum fact that there's discreet set of possible answers to this
question. Is it's spinning clockwise or counterclockwise, yes or no.
It's just those two possibilities. Nowhere in between. So if you're,
if you have a magnetic field that is oriented vertically,
send your electron through it. It gets deflected up. You say, Oh, it's spin up.
So now measured it spin. Now I know what its state is.
If I send it through another magnetic field or oriented vertically,
it will always be deflected up every single time we know what it is we're going
to measure it. Measuring it in this case doesn't change it.
It's in exactly that state. We know it. Okay,
now let's send it through a magnetic field that is oriented horizontally,
so it's going to be deflected either right or left.
We know exactly what state it's in, it's spinning this way,
but when you send it through that magnetic field that's oriented horizontally,
it gets deflected, left or right, 50 50 unpredictably.
There's no way we can predict it and then once it is, so okay,
now it's been spinning up. You measured it, spinned, left.
Let's say send it through another magnet that is going vertically and now it's
50 50 again, it could be spin up or spin down. So somehow,
even though we knew exactly what state it was in,
we couldn't predict what would happen next. That is part of quantum mechanics.
So the act of sending it through these things where it makes it vertical or
horizontal in what is what is happening to it.
When it's going through these things. So in quantum mechanics,
what we say is that it's not that we don't know whether the electron is spinning
clockwise or counterclockwise. Um, it can be in a super position of both.
That's just the spin version of the position that the electron can be spread out
in a, in a wave, right? It's,
it's truly not just that we are lacking some knowledge is that the knowledge
really isn't there. And again,
this is how we teach quantum mechanics in textbooks.
And then I'm going to correct it cause many worlds is much better.
But this is the standard textbook version. There's a wave function.
The wave function for a spin is it's either up or down or some combination.
And then there's a rule that says when you measure the spin,
you only get up or down. You don't see the wave function,
just like the cloud that you have for the electrons position.
When you look at it, you see it at a location.
So another way to get to make the same argument is take a little piece of,
I have a nice little image of this when I give talks, a little piece of uranium.
So it's a radioactive, a little chunk of metal,
and you put it in a bubble chamber.
So it is emitting radioactive particles and you detect the particles.
You can see a little streak of a of motion when the particle leaves the uranium.
Okay, well, like I said, when you're not looking at it,
this electron is supposed to obey in equation the Schrodinger equation.
And you can ask what the prediction is.
When when a radioactive nucleus decays and gives off an electron,
what is its wave function going to do?
What is the wave functioning electron going to be?
And the answer is it goes off in a spherical wave.
It goes off in all directions at once evenly. Yeah, all directions evenly.
But you never see that. Is that [inaudible] the shape of the piece of uranium?
Does it vary? No,
because the electron gets from one individual nucleus of an atom. Right?
So the the what the, the uranium is doing doesn't matter.
It's just that one Adam matters.
And the easiest thing for the electron to do is just to go out in a sphere.
It doesn't have to, he can go out and higher energy States. But the point is,
it's not going out in a straight line, but when you look at it,
you see a straight line, right?
That's the fundamental mystery of quantum mechanics.
That how we described the thing when we're not looking at it is different than
what we see when we look at it.
So when you're in pursuit of an understanding,
a deeper understanding of, of quantum mechanics, what you,
when you,
you're thinking about people from the 19 hundreds that are just sort of
basically getting the first steps going to understand this stuff.
When,
when you're talking about this lack of funding and the lack of encouragement for
people to pursue quantum mechanics,
you strongly feel like there are answers to these questions. Yeah,
that's right. That we just need better tools and a better understanding,
better equations. More time.
Yeah, me and Einstein think that's right.
So Einstein is one of the secret heroes of the book because he has this
reputation as someone who just couldn't quite accept quantum mechanics. Uh,
the title is something deeply hidden as a quote from Einstein. Uh,
when he was talking about when he was a kid and he had a compass, right?
And he was given his first magnetic compass and he could rotate it this way and
that way. And it always pointed North and you and I would go, huh, that's cool.
But he was Einstein. He's like, wow, this is amazing. Why?
How does it know where North is? Right? And he said,
there must be something deeply hidden that explains why it's doing this
mysterious thing. And he felt the same way about quantum mechanics that we have.
We gave these set of rules,
orchard called the Copenhagen interpretation of quantum mechanics.
One set of rules for when you're looking at it,
one set of rules for when you're not. And Einstein was like, Oh, come on.
Clearly this is not the final answer to the nature of reality, right?
He wanted you to know God's thoughts. He's like,
I want to know everything we're not done yet. There must be more going on.
And so many worlds is one of the proposed answers to what could be going on.
It's not the only one. There's alternatives, but it's definitely my favorite.
It's definitely the easiest one to uh, to write down. Let's put it that way.
Okay, so hit us with this many worlds theory. Okay.
So think about this electron. You're gonna you,
you say that it could be either spin up or spin down.
It's a combination of both. That's its wave function. You measure it.
You only ever see spin up or spin down.
So Copenhagen says that's because the wave function suddenly changed,
snapped into place when you observed it.
Don't ask me what it means to observe something that's not what Copenhagen lets
you ask many worlds.
Says what you're missing is two things. Number one,
your a quantum system. You are obeying the rules of quantum mechanics.
You're made of atoms and electrons and so forth. You have a wave function to,
okay,
so you're secretly treating yourself as a classical thing when you make that
measurement. But you really should be treating yourself quantum mechanically.
Right? That's one thing. And the other thing is, uh,
something that Einstein invented, namely called entanglement.
When quantum says there's a wave function for a system,
it doesn't say there's a separate wave function for every particle, right?
It says that there's only one wave function for the whole universe.
So the way I like to say it is imagine two particles come in and bounce off of
each other. Either one has a wave function and it's, you know, unpredictable.
Exactly what angle it's going to go off at. So both of them,
both of the particles that go off, you don't know where they're going,
but because momentum is conserved, if they came in at equal velocities,
they'll go out at equal velocities in opposite directions. If you measure one,
then you know where the other one is going, right? That's entanglement.
The observed state of one system can be related to the observed state of another
system. So those are the two ingredients.
Your quantum system and quantum systems can be entangled with each other.
So whoever it,
who was a graduate student when he invented this idea in the 1950s said, look,
when you measure that electron, what happens physically? Look,
forget about you're a person, you're conscious, all of that BS.
Like you're a physical system. You obey the Schrodinger equation. You,
you are quantum mechanical system. You obey the laws of physics.
So you look at the electron, your wave function changes.
It used to be you're just a person doing whatever you do.
But then after you look at the electron,
you become entangled with it and it splits.
So there is one part of the wave function that says the electron was spinning
clockwise and you measured,
it's spinning clockwise and there's another part of the wave function that says
the electron was spinning counterclockwise and you saw it spinning
counter-clockwise. Now everybody knows this like that that far.
It's not controversial at all.
That's clearly the prediction of the equations of quantum mechanics.
But everyone else said, well, that means that I'm some weird combination of,
I saw it spinning one way and I saw it spinning the other way,
but I've never felt that way. When I look at real electrons,
I see them one way or the other. That can't be right.
That can't be the final answer.
The way function must somehow collapse and Everett said no.
What you're missing is there's now two separate worlds.
Both of those part of the wave function are real, but they're different worlds.
They will never interact with each other again.
What happens in one part of the wave function will not affect what happens in
the other part.
So now there's a version of you that's all the electrons spinning clockwise and
there's another version of you that saw spinning counterclockwise and that's
just taking seriously the prediction of quantum mechanics.
It's not adding any extra stuff, any extra worlds, anything like that.
That is the part where my brain broke the,
the idea that there's a you that observes it going clockwise and the you that
observes it going in a different direction like that is so hard to understand.
Do you, do you apply this in your regular life? Like, do you think,
like when you go home and you say hi to your wife and you open up the
frigerator,
do you think of yourself as this quantum being that's existing in this
superstate?
So, I mean, there's a couple of answers to that. One is, you know, sure.
If I think about it, like I really do believe it. You know,
I have a chapter in the book, which my editor resisted at first,
but then he let me get away with it,
which is a dialogue between a young philosopher.